I'm here to share a truth with you.
And so I am ready to share my truth.
And the truth is,
I love scam artists.
I mean, I don't love scam artists,
I love learning about them.
I love reading books about them,
watching documentaries about them,
I love learning about the teleshopping
queen Wanna Marchi in Italy.
I like learning how to avoid
creeps like Simon Leviev,
you know, the "Tinder Swindler."
I even liked watching both Fyre Festival
documentaries the day they came out
and have listened
to every single radio edit
of every Billy McFarland interview
that exists in this dimension.
I'm, like, obsessed.
And I think we can all learn a lot
from scam artists, you know,
not like how to live
your life or something,
but specifically how money
functions in our society.
So if you're ready to go
on this journey with me today,
I would like to teach you money lessons
from famous scam artists.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
(Applause)
So how did I get here?
Well, I'm an artist,
you know, minus the scam part.
I'm a poet and a filmmaker specifically.
And when I started my arts journey
full-time over a decade ago,
I was unprepared for the amount
of grants I'd have to write.
Turns out that a lot of being
a professional artist
is fundraising for your own salary.
So I got good at grants.
I got so good at grants,
I started writing grants for other people.
In one year alone,
through writing grants for folks,
running people's fundraising campaigns,
supporting mutual aid efforts,
I was able to help move
1.3 million dollars
directly into the hands of Black
trans individuals and organizations.
(Applause and cheers)
I started consulting
with philanthropic organizations
on the best way to support
targeted communities,
and I teach reparations frameworks
all across the country.
So I know why people give money.
And honestly, a lot of it
is great storytelling,
and scam artists are really good
at spinning a narrative.
Now, the first famous scam artist
I'd like to tell you all about
is the infamous Elizabeth Holmes.
So Elizabeth Holmes, who founded Theranos,
was able to rake in
about a nine-billion-dollar valuation
for a product that didn't even work.
For those of you that don't remember
Elizabeth Holmes, because you somehow,
I don't know, like, missed
the competing podcast, the book,
the documentary and the very public trial,
let me remind you who she is.
So she started Theranos under the premise
that they would be creating a device
that could read hundreds of medical tests
through a single drop of blood.
Now she surrounded herself
with government officials,
venture capitalists and a bevy
of high-gloss magazine covers.
What she did not surround herself with,
though, were medical experts as peers,
right?
And so for many people,
and for many of them
that came close to her,
they could realize pretty quickly
that what she was selling
just wasn't real.
And so for most folks, it's very clear
that Elizabeth Holmes is a scammer.
But have you ever listened
to the rationalizations of her funders?
That stuff is gold.
So out of all of her investors,
my favorite interview
is one with Don Lucas Sr.
So Don Lucas Sr.,
who gave her millions of dollars,
was asked to explain,
"Why did you give her so much money?"
And so he said, "Well, her great-
grandfather was an entrepreneur."
And it turns out the hospital
near where her family lives
is named for her great-uncle.
Yeah, so she was supposedly
the best of both worlds
and had supposedly learned both medicine
and entrepreneurship through osmosis.
(Laughter)
Another gem of an interview
was with Tim Draper.
So Tim Draper pushed back against
an interviewer who asked,
"Now, do you think that Elizabeth Holmes,
being a family friend of yours,
had anything to do with you
giving her so much money?"
He scoffed.
I mean, he's a professional.
He doesn't do trivial things like that.
He was a first investor
in Tesla and Skype.
He just knows who's going
to go the distance.
And as we know, Theranos tanked,
horribly and publicly,
after opening 40 centers
at Arizona-based Walgreens locations
and endangering thousands of people
who got blood tests
that the company knew
were going to be faulty.
A lie we get told again and again,
is that broke folks are bad at money.
It's working-class folks who make
bad decisions about money.
This brings us to our first lesson.
People with wealth aren't better
at making decisions.
They get to make more bad decisions
without it hurting them.
(Applause)
With the added bonus of being able
to cause extensive harm
to the people over whom they wield power.
When broke folks make
bad decisions about money,
it only impacts them,
not whole ecosystems.
The next famous scam artist
I'd like to talk to you all about
is the story of Margaret and Walter Keane.
Now in the 1960s,
Walter got famous for painting.
But guess what Walter doesn't do?
Walter doesn’t paint, OK?
He steals all of the work
from Margaret, right?
And these beautiful pieces,
known for their resonant features
of children with big eyes,
were shown off at clubs,
at festivals, even at the UN.
They made him millions of dollars.
He even had celebrity clientele
such as the Kennedy family.
Because of the difficulty
of being taken seriously
as an artist who was a woman,
it was easy to erase Margaret
from her work.
Walter even was able to convince her
that this was the best way
to get her work seen at all.
Which brings us to our next point
and lesson for the day.
In an unjust society,
our social identities
are often used as markers
to decide whether we are worthy
of being taken seriously
or deserving of financial
and other resources, OK?
And when I'm saying other resources,
I'm saying sometimes it's money,
sometimes it's food,
sometimes it's housing,
sometimes it's water.
The next story that's coming up to me
actually is not a scam
artist story per se,
but a triumph over scam artist story.
If I can diverge just for a little bit,
is that OK, yeah?
And so I'm thinking so much
about the story of Carlette Duffy.
So Carlette Duffy is a Black woman
based in Indianapolis.
And in 2020, she decided
that she needed to refinance her home.
And so when she did that,
she had two appraisal teams come down,
and they both undervalued
her home extensively.
The lowest appraisal
being at 110,000 dollars.
So she had an idea.
She took down every picture
of her family from her home.
She removed every single piece of artwork
that depicted Black people.
She removed all of her hair products
and she called a friend,
a white man that news outlets
simply refer to as "Hank."
Well, don't you know that when Hank
stood in for her at the next appraisal,
her home went from being worth
110,000 dollars to 259,000 dollars.
Does that sound like a scam to you?
Because it sounds like a scam to me.
And in that story,
what I think also comes up,
is how common that scam is.
And it is one that's based
in redlining practices
and white supremacy culture.
Now the next and last scam artist
that I would like to share with y'all
is the amazing Anna Sorokin,
aka Anna Delvey, OK?
Yeah, so some of y'all are fans,
I could tell, OK.
Hide your wallets, OK?
And so ...
So Anna Delvey pretended
to be a German heiress,
and she almost, every space she went into,
she took the New York scene of financial
institutions and socialites for a ride
that would cost them 275,000 dollars.
She lived in sprawling apartments,
she flew on private jets,
she vacationed on yachts,
she ate meals that cost
as much as my rent.
She said she was rich.
She looked the part.
And so as a result, people felt compelled
to give her more money.
Think of how ridiculous that sounds.
Because she said she was rich,
she looked the part,
people thought she also
needed their money.
Whether a gift or a loan,
Anna would always promise
to pay people back
that decided they wanted to help her
in supposedly urgent situations
when she wasn't able to access
her totally fictional
but supposedly sprawling fortune.
What Anna's story reminds me
is this next point.
Again, in an unjust system,
in an unjust society,
those who are seen as being able
to perform wealth
are more likely to get funded
than those in actual financial need.
Not only is this a gross practice,
it's an unsustainable one.
In 2014, a study found
that overconsumption
and economic inequality leads
to the collapse of civilizations.
While having a lot of wealth
may be able to buy you a PR team
to make you more likable
to the general population,
it doesn't make you a more skilled person.
It doesn't make you more capable,
and it certainly doesn't
make you more perceptive
about the sustainability of resources.
This idea that wealthy people
are somehow more deserving
is one that is very pervasive
and one that many different
types of people believe.
In this society, because of all
the systems we live under,
lots of broke folks also believe the idea
that they are somehow less worthy
than their wealthy counterparts.
Scam artists actually know something
that most of us in this room
would deny or refuse to accept.
And that is,
money doesn't typically come
from hard work.
Money comes to those who hoard it.
Money comes to those
who are willing to exploit.
Money comes to those who work hard
to bury the history
of where money comes from.
Billions of people live on this planet
that work hard every single day
that will live and die broke.
Money comes to financial institutions
like Bank of America
and JPMorgan Chase,
who literally got their start
in the transatlantic slave trade
and will find themselves
in the news every few years
for denying loans to the very descendants
of the same people they once owned.
To big tech giants like Apple and Amazon,
who will pay top dollar
for a coder behind a desk in Seattle
but will pay darn near nothing
for the hands of those
that work tirelessly
to mine the materials
that make our devices function
and to deliver our packages cheaply.
To living in a society where it is legal
to pay both disabled workers
and essential workers
less than minimum wage.
The way we deal with money
in this society is the real scam.
And while the scam artists
that I'm talking about
have had their tricks and tools exposed
for the whole world to see,
there are scams in our faces
every single day.
So what do I want you to get out of today?
I want you to consider
that there are scams that we are asked
to agree not to see all the time.
And I want you to think
about in your personal life,
in your interpersonal life
and in your greater community life,
what are some scams
that we are asked to pretend are OK
and understanding that when we do that,
we set up a lot
of our communities to fail.
As an artist, I have
the distinct pleasure and joy
of helping people to dream possibilities
that don't already exist on this planet.
So today I'm asking you to dream with me.
I want you to dream a possible world
in which we delegate resources like money
from a place of community care.
What do actual ethical practices
around money look like?
Money in this society
is often used to prove morality,
competency, wisdom,
when really it's just a tool we made up.
And we get to decide how we use it,
how we move forward with it
or without it for the collective good.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)